de l'attente toujours plus d'attentes
les jours se suivent et se ressemblent
dans beaucoup d'aéroports ou quatre
coins du monde
comme Hamsterdam ou le manque de
personnel cause des retards depuis des
semaines
ce qui se passe ici n'est pas normal
c'est un vrai drame dites a peur de
rater son vol pour Aruba
j'espère qu'il y aura bientôt une
solution et que les gens pourront
profiter de leurs vacances après la
pandémie
en Suède aussi les voyageurs nagent en
pleine confusion ici c'est une grève des
pilotes qui cloue les avions au sol ma
veste
d'Arlanda à gotenburg un vol local qui a
finalement été annulé à la dernière
minute
on va devoir rentrer à la maison et
prendre la voiture se résister
nous sommes vraiment dévastés ça devait
être l'été de la reprise à déplorer un
patron de scanner generalines une
tentative d'apaisement car la colère des
passagers commence à se tourner vers les
compagnies aériennes
Royaume-Uni un patron d'easyJet a
démissionné après avoir été blâmé pour
l'annulation de centaines de vols
et aux États-Unis aussi des voies
s'élèvent pour demander des comptes aux
compagnies aériennes
elles ont reçu du financement public et
elles doivent livrer la marchandise à
marteler le secrétaire au transport
pitbull jazz car les aéroports
américains n'ont plus n'échappent pas au
chaos
de voyage et deux vols retardés cette
passagère n'est toujours pas arrivé à
destination
j'en ai assez une phrase qui résume
l'état d'esprit de beaucoup de voyageurs
alors que la haute saison s'annonce de
plus en plus haute en stress et en
imprévu ici Radio-Canada Toronto